afternoon session
um
it is my pleasure to introduce our first
speaker priya morgani from uc berkeley
who's going to talk about how very big
uh large-scale omix data sets are
helping her to understand the evolution
of the germline mutation rate in humans
hi everyone thanks for joining the
afternoon session and to the organizers
for giving me an opportunity to share
some of our recent work with you
as way of introduction my lab works on
genomic data and there are three main
questions that we ask in our lab one of
them is to understand how evolutionary
processes generate all the genetic
radiation we observe around us
we then try to use this understanding as
a molecular clock to learn about when
different evolutionary events occurred
in our history
and use that to then understand human
adaptation and disease um how do can can
everyone hear me clearly do you prefer
if i remove my mask or keep it on okay
um
and so today i'm actually going to talk
about this very first topic because it's
really fundamental to everything that we
do in our lab and in general in
evolutionary biology
and
understanding the germline mutation rate
is really important for
because it's the main source of
evolutionary novelty it's the cause of
many heritable diseases and cancers and
also because mutations occur steadily
over time they provide a record of the
time elapsed and hence act as a
molecular clock for learning about when
different evolutionary events occurred
okay i might remove my mask
the question of mutation rate is as i
said really fundamental to everything we
do and the earliest estimates of
mutation rate actually date back to
1930s even before it was appreciated
that dna is the hereditary material some
seminal work done by uh haldane
measured the rate of hemophilia in
families and tried to infer what the
mutation rate might be
and today with large omics data sets
everything that we know about mutation
rate is being revised there are large
data sets now available for pedigrees
these are
trios either father mother and child or
large families data for thousands of
different uh individuals
and also large amounts of data across
different species we've seen some of
these discussed at this meeting also
with the earth biome project and the
darwin's tree of life project and all of
this is really revising how what we
think of mutation rate
so uh let's first
review what we really know about
mutation rate so the textbook view of
mutation rates is that mutations occur
during development in onto genesis where
uh in oocytes all the mutations occur by
the birth of the future mother and in
spermatogonial cells these divide uh
during development and then divide
post-puberty uh in males
such that if you wanted to build a model
we could then just conceptualize this as
there are large number of divisions in
females between conception and birth and
then there is a period of stasis where
there are no more uh cell divisions in
the female germ line in males the uh
some cell divisions occur during
conception and birth then there is a
period of spaces until puberty and then
post puberty the male germ line again
the spermatogonial cells continue
dividing each mutation is an oper each
cell division is an opportunity for uh
some errors to occur and those can get
passed on to the next generation as the
germline mutations so the number of
mutations in an offspring then depends
upon the different stage at which the
mutations occur so the uh different
number of cell divisions that occur in
each of these stages and the mutation
rate in these stages
now let's look at what we learned from
the
sequencing of families we can directly
sequence the genome of the parents and
the offspring and then at each position
of the genome we can ask does the
sequence of the offspring differ from
that of the parents you control for
certain uh errors in sequencing coverage
fill apply filters to be sure that this
is not just a false positive or an
artifact of sequencing but indeed
actually a germline
mutation
mutation and then you can simply ask how
does the mutation rate depend upon the
age of the parents
on average we find that an offspring has
around 70 denervo mutations uh between
70 to 100 actually and this depends upon
the age of the parents for every year
increase in the father's age and
offspring gets additional 1.5 mutations
and for every year increase in the
mother's age the offspring gets 0.4
additional mutation the father's age of
course is consistent with what i showed
you that there are continuous divisions
on the male germ line but the
mother's age effect is quite puzzling
and you would expect that there should
be a flat line here because there should
be no increase in the number of
mutations with the age of the mother
because the orgonial cells are not
dividing
however mutations can occur both because
of dna damage these can be endogenous or
exogenous
sources of damage that can lead to uh
germline mutations and so in the females
you can expect that there is increase in
the rate due to dna damage and then in
the
male term line you can expect that this
is because of replication errors and uh
dna damage and on average males have
three four uh three males contribute
three-fourth of the mutations and
females contribute one-fourth so on
average males have like contribute three
times more mutations than uh the females
and you would expect that this is
largely because of the increased
mutations for puberty in males however
with this data we can also partition the
male bias in mutation with age so you
can go in and look at all the pedigrees
whose parents were around 20 years of
age and estimate what is the male bias
and mutation rate and then similarly you
can estimate the male bias with
increasing age of the parents and what
you find is surprisingly a flat line we
expect this line to be increasing
linearly or even others have been even
suggested exponentially with age but
instead we find a flat line this
suggests that potentially more mutations
are occurring due to dna damage which
might be similar in males and females we
can also look at this across different
species so here each point is data for
pedigrees in that species and what we
are looking at is just the proportion of
paternal mutations at average age in
these species and despite these species
ranging in different
parental ages or different generation
times mating systems we find that the
male bias and mutation rate is roughly
constant with age and this suggests that
mutations not only occur due to
replication errors but they also occur
in large part due to non-replicative
sources or dna damage which can be both
endogenous and
exogenous and this uh well mirrors the
literature from cancer genomics where we
are also finding that uh exogenous and
endogenous sources can also have a big
impact on mutation rate
another thing we can do is we can divide
the mutations in the context in which
they occur so we can look at the type of
mutation so looking at c to g versus c
to a mutations and then we can
investigate how the rate of mutation
changes with the age of the parents
we divide the mutations in different
types because these give us hints about
what the underlying mechanism might be
so if you look at cpg mutations these
primarily occur due to methylation
driven mutations and since the male germ
line is methylated for a longer period
than the female germ line what you find
is that uh there is increase in mutation
rate with the father's age and not
really with the mother's age we can also
look at other types of mutations like c
to g mutations and we seem to increase
disproportionately with the mother's age
versus the father's age and we know from
their
location and other investigation that
these mutations are largely happening
due to double strand breaks
and so this means that not only the
mutation rate but actually the spectrum
of mutations or the proportions of
different types of mutations varies
across different
uh
across males and females
now another uh classic discovery in
evolutionary biology is the use of the
molecular clock we tend to assume that
the mutation rate is constant with
age and so we can use divergence across
different species and infer what is the
time of uh divergence now if we look at
uh closely related species here i'm
showing you 10 different primates and we
look at neutral substitutions in these
primates and then estimate how
different these rates are we find that
the rates differ quite substantially we
find that if you compare humans and
chimpanzees the rates differ by about
two percent humans and oranges or other
apes differ by almost 10 percent
apes and old world monkeys defer by 40
percent the rates are about 40 percent
higher in uh old world monkeys and
almost uh twofold higher in new world
monkeys compared to apes again we can
break down the mutations by the type so
we can look at 80 transitions or cpg
transitions and we find even the
proportions of these mutations differ
across different primates suggesting
that not only the mutation rate but the
spectrum is also changing across closely
related species
a third surprise has been that even huma
across human populations there are
differences in mutation rate there's
essentially no base composition across
human populations the replication
machinery is very similar or is
identical across humans and yet when you
estimate the rate of say c to a
mutations or the proportions of c to a
mutations in different contexts in
europeans or africans you start finding
that these rates differ here the uh each
of these comparisons looks at a
different context
and the colors indicate the how
significantly different the rates are
all the blocks with dots are showing you
that these are significant differences
after correcting for multiple hypothesis
testing now one of the most significant
differences is a mutation
type called tcc to ttc mutations where
you find that this mutation is present
at about 20 percent higher frequency in
europeans compared to other non-european
populations
and
this transient change has been suggested
to perhaps be because of uv exposure or
genetic modifiers and i'll talk about
this example further in the next few
slides also
so let's just look at what are some of
the processes that impact mutation rate
so in enough each offspring has its own
mutation spectrum and this spectrum
depends upon the parental age as i
showed you it also depends upon
environmental exposures it also depends
upon the replication machinery of the
parents or dna modifiers in their
genomes over time this forms the
mutation spectrum of a population but
there are other factors that matter in
this case also
one is demography that matters another
one is selection selection purges out
deleterious mutations and another factor
that matters is biased gene conversion
this is a bias in how you repair dna so
in a heteroduplex when you have a
mismatch there's a preferential bias
towards repairing from the uh from c to
g basis versus d to a basis so this acts
like selection where over time this
shifts the genome towards being a more
gc genome and there are counteracting
forces in the genome that bring it back
to equilibrium where the gc content
doesn't change much but there can be
subtle differences because of biased
gene conversion also now when we look at
this composite effect at the end after
many many generations any of these
factors could actually matter and we
don't we can't really conclude that the
differences we are observing today are
because of parental age or dna modifiers
or environmental exposures and so for
the rest of the talk this is the
question that i'll focus on and how we
did some recent work to try to
understand what might be some of the
causes of the differences we are
observing in humans
and this is work uh jointly led with
zive gao who's at university of
pennsylvania and by a graduate student
in my group yulin zhang
and the question we asked is how many
changes have occurred in the human
mutation spectrum when and in which
populations did these occur and what are
some of the causes of these differences
and
for the last question in the interest of
time i won't go through all the parts
but i'll show you some uh hints at what
we are learning
so in order to
really understand what are some of the
causes we developed a new framework
where we
tried to add a time dimension to
understand when the differences occur
across populations and we also control
for effects of selection and biased gene
conversion so in order to add the time
dimension what we did is we took all the
data from thousand genomes project and
we reconstructed the entire ancestral
recombination graph of these individuals
what that mean is means is just a fancy
way of saying we did some genealogical
reconstruction such that we divided the
genome into bits where there is no
recombination and we try to build trees
in those recombinations
in those regions and then we place down
mutations on these trees such that the
branch line tells us what the time of
the mutation is we we do this for every
population um together and then
separately also estimate the ages of the
mutations so that now we can tell if we
are looking at a mutation
that is 10 generations old it's the same
mutation similar type age of mutations
in other populations also
to control for bias gene conversion what
we do is we look at mutation types that
are similarly impacted by biased gene
conversion i told you the predominant
bias is between towards a shift from
weaker bases that is t
a and t to stronger bases that is c and
g and so we can just compare mutation
types like uh t to c and t to g which
are both favored by bias gene conversion
similarly we can look at mutations which
are not affected by biased gene
conversion like c to g mutations or t2a
mutations and so rather than comparing
the total number of mutations or the or
the proportions of mutations what we do
is we compare ratios of mutations and in
order to
control for selection we just remove
regions that might be selected uh and we
have many ways of trying to control even
for link selection where we can look at
mostly neutral mutations in the genome
and so this is what we uh get at the end
of our uh
after applying a framework on the y-axis
is the age of every mutation in the
genome we have about
10 million mutations in this analysis
what we have done is we've just divided
it by the ages these estimates are in
generations for every mutation we can
estimate how when did this mutation
arise based on our genealogical
reconstruction we can then estimate the
ratio of two types of mutations uh and
then here we are looking at let's say
the 48 to 107 generation mutations we've
been this uh mutations in different uh
bins of equal size we've done the
binning in many different ways and so
the binning doesn't really affect things
and then we estimate the ratio of these
two types of mutations for all the
mutations at this particular age we can
repeat this exercise for different age
bins for different types of mutations
and when we do this very
nicely we confirm the european specific
acceleration that was found in the
previous analysis uh so in this analysis
i was showing you data for northern
europeans and we find this acceleration
that i had shown you earlier also like
the other study
we can also do the same analysis for
multiple populations here we are looking
at one northern european population east
asian population and a west african
population we do the analysis similarly
for each population separately and then
we can compare how different these
different populations are or at what
rate these mutations occur and when we
do this we find that there are three key
differences we find the european
acceleration at this uh tcc mutations
which is at c2t c2a mutations at non-cpg
sites we also find a new signal where we
find that there is divergence of c to g
to t2a ratios across
all human populations interestingly
whatever the cause might be is still
ongoing because the differences are
present even in the most recent time
been whereas with the
tcc mutation you find that whatever the
causes were no longer are active and
such that all human populations have the
same rates now and we find surprisingly
a third signal which is present at the t
to c to t to g mutations at very old
mutations uh and these uh mutations
predate out of africa migration such
that all these mutations must have
arisen in the common ancestors of all
modern humans that that there are no
population differences at this stage
except our analysis suggests that there
might be some differences at this stage
so i'll now go through each one of these
signals and turn to show you how we are
trying to understand the mechanisms that
underlie these
for the tcc signal a lot of analysis has
previously been done that suggests that
there are certain mutational contexts
that are enriched for these mutations
these contacts are actually surprisingly
linked to uv exposure and are often seen
in skin cancers where the tcc context
plus some additional context appear to
be driving these differences
and so what we first did is in our
framework try to look at specifically
this context to see if we also see
enrichment in these contexts and indeed
our signals are significant in this case
we also applied it after removing this
context so we remove all of these
extended context and we still find that
there are differences across europeans
and non-europeans suggesting that
whatever
the causes are are not solely driven by
these uh mutational contexts and so it's
always it's been really puzzling to
think of how uv might affect the
germline
and so in some ways this is reassuring
that while this is correlated to the
signal it's probably not driving the
signal we have some other uh
results in the lab which we are still
investigating which suggests that there
are certain loss of function mutations
in certain mismatch repair gene that
might be causing these differences this
is consistent with another hypothesis
that was also put forth by uh the
original study uh from jonathan
pritchard and kelly harris that
suggested that this might be related to
genetic modifiers which might be
segregating in human populations and
that might have led to some differences
uh others have also suggested that maybe
the mean age of reproduction differs
across
europeans and non-europeans and that
might be driving these differences and
we are investigating all of these
hypotheses
another signal i showed you is the c to
g to t2a
signal
in order to understand which uh which of
these mutation types is driving this
signal we first looked at we took these
ratios and just changed the numerator in
this case to figure out if which one of
these is driving the signal so first we
looked at the t to g to t2a mutations we
found that there were still significant
differences in these bins we looked at
t to c to t to a differences we still
found the differences but however when
we look at c to g to c two a mutations
we find that there are almost no
significant differences and so we find
that these mutations are actually driven
by a change in the t2a mutation rates we
still don't know what the cause of this
is we have looked at signatures but we
can't really find anything in the
annotated cancer literature or
environmental exposure literature to
figure out what might be causing these
differences the one exciting thing about
this mutation type as i mentioned is
that these differences are still present
in uh in human populations so whatever
the forces that differentiates this
mutations is still
present and potentially we can sequence
pedigrees and try to learn about what
these causes might be
and now i'll talk about the third signal
which is in some ways
one of my one of the most interesting uh
to me which i which is because these
mutations that where we find differences
across africans and non-africans appear
to have occurred are dated to be very
old and yet uh there seem to be
population differences and so first we
were sure that this might be because of
technical errors in particular all of
the results that i'm showing you is for
derived variants so these are mutations
that arose on the human lineage
since separation from chimpanzees and so
we figured that perhaps there was some
error in our polarization of the data
and so we tried to repolarize the data
using chimpanzees and we found that the
signal is still present in fact even
stronger
and then we reason that one difference
between africans and non-africans is
their history of neanderthal ancestry we
might predict that if there are certain
variants that integrates from
neanderthals into non-africans those
might look very different compared to
the variance in the common ancestor of
all modern humans and so if we could
fight identify the neanderthal
introgressed variants and remove those
from our analysis we would not see any
of these differences
and when we do this analysis we actually
still find the differences are quite
significant across humans suggesting
that this difference is not driven by
neanderthal gene flow in non-africans
next thing we did is further try to
use this idea of polarizing the data by
looking at uh the sharing with different
arcade populations and trying to figure
out when these mutations arose did they
arise here uh on the neanderthal lineage
so that they integrate back into
non-africans this is the hypothesis we
tested in the previous
slide we also looked at mutations
perhaps that arose on the denisovan
lineage and introgressed into uh modern
humans or the mutations that arose in
this shared branch across all uh
modern humans and archaic populations so
here are the results if we look at just
denisova derived mutations we find still
and remove them we still see there are
significant differences such that these
are not driving the signal we can do the
same with neanderthal derived mutations
again like the previous slide we see
these mutations uh these are not driving
the signal but if you remove these
shared mutations that are extremely old
and predate the separation of modern
humans and arcade populations it seems
that these are the mutations that are
driving the signal
it's the model uh that uh oh and so then
we also try to figure out again is it
the t2c or t2g mutation
in this case we borrowed ideas from
cancer literature where we looked at
what are some of the signatures in which
these mutations occur
and we identified a couple of mutational
contexts that appear to be driving these
mutations in particular one signature at
t2c mutations in these three contexts
appears to be entirely driving the
differences across human populations
suggesting that either genetic modifiers
or some exogenous forces that might
leave behind this footprint is causing
these differences
and so the model that emerges from these
analysis is that at some point in the
past there were some mutational changes
in an ancient ancestor of ours and these
mutations are now present in modern
humans either potentially through gene
flow back into modern humans or due to
population structure
others have proposed that there might be
two possibilities that there is some
ghost ancestry in african and non-uh
african populations uh mutations that
arose at some point in the past that
introgressed into uh at this point in
human uh evolution this figure is
entirely from this paper and not related
to our analysis it just coincidentally
fits very well with our results
another model that has been proposed is
this model of
structure in the stem population of
humans where there is evidence from the
fossil record that there is there were
many many human populations um at some
point in the past and these might
actually have uh differential
contributions to living humans today
and today we are now investigating uh
which one of these models fits our data
better
so some implications of this analysis is
that we find that there are not many
non-replicated sources that can also
impact uh that have non-negligible force
in shaping the mutation spectrum like
replicated mutations demography and
admixture has pervasive impacts on
shaping
our genetic variation and even impacts
very fundamental uh processes like
mutation rate uh and also this has
some important implications for
molecular clock and its use where we
find that it's very unsteady at short
time scales where the rates defer by 10
to 15 across human populations but
puzzlingly across humans and chimpanzees
they defer only by 2 so there must be
some stabilizing selection to keep
mutation rate at a lower uh rate and to
have uh to have similar rates across
groups we are now looking at these
questions using other kinds of omics
data in particular non-human species
data looking at single cell sequencing
data and then looking leveraging hybrid
genomes where we can actually look at
the uh two copies of different genomes
in the same uh cell and then see how
those get affected by
different replication uh machinery
uh with that i would like to thank my
collaborators in particular zbegaw and
yulin zhang who led much of the work uh
i'd like to thank all my funding sources
in particular korea for funding the
research on the mutation rate uh and my
lab for very helpful discussions
throughout the projects thank you very
much
[Applause]
that's cool you can infer so back in
time much so far back in time in a
population specific way yeah we have a
couple questions
[Music]
thanks so much it was really wonderful
to see this work with them with the args
are very very very smart and thousand
genomes i i had one basic question maybe
i misunderstood this but
you know mapping the mutation signatures
in the thousand genomes data is really
germline and you can look historically
where mutations occur
if you map this to this cast signatures
you know isn't that surprising that you
find uv signatures because that's a
somatic mutation so how does that get
into the germline you know obviously
oocytes don't get all that much sun and
neither does male sperm so
do you have an explanation for that and
yeah would you not also have to measure
somatic mutations in this sexual tissues
to really map this over i mean that
seemed very puzzling to me that you
could find those yeah so it is very
puzzling to almost everybody because we
don't expect the germline to be impacted
by uv
and so it's been quite puzzling to see
this matching of the signature i think
this is correlation and not causation
though we are investigating that
i think we don't have to be concerned
about the somatic versus germline
analysis because in the
uh when you sequence a uh pool of cells
you predominantly pick up the germline
mutations in those cells and we are not
looking at sort of the minority
population as people do for somatic
cells
we have also replicated this uh anal
replicated these results in multiple
other data sets and they seem to be
quite robust
uh i think it's actually a correlation
and we have some hints with a gene that
appears to be
potentially has a loss of function uh
mutation and that might be driving the
difference
yeah awesome
so
one of the big conundrums in
sort of cross cross-population studies
are the different kinds of cancers that
you get in different populations
right her2-positive
er positive versus not
and b-raf
is super interesting because there's
this this super recurrent
v600e
yeah mutation it's the one that like
there was a massive paper
a couple weeks ago that everybody got
cured right right with this
immunotherapy so that v-raf v600e
mutation is actually a perfect control
for you yeah for the t to a versus the
cdg yeah that's a great idea because
in fact when you i just sort of looked
it up when you look at v600
e to d yeah in cancer like you'd expect
50 50 based on
right because of the four-fold
degeneracy doesn't add in fact it's like
95
v to e versus v to d
and so you have this circulating
impact of this that then goes to all of
these other tissues so
it could go
gonadal even if its
origin is somewhere else yeah yeah right
so important point we'll try to look for
specifically that type of mutation to
see if that's leading to the differences
my suggestion is actually slightly which
is look at the um if you can
data from
liquid biopsy
okay because that circulating cell free
dna data
may actually be different among current
ethnic groups in a way that could allow
you to test some of this with the
natural controls that there are
in the genetic code because if you could
tie it back to that yeah absolutely
there's even another element which is
the role that
hla and other circulating
kind of natural suppressors of these are
having because my guess is it's not
crazy right like humans didn't need to
adapt to live at
not only the uv light but altitude that
gives you different spectrum of mutation
for a long time so anyway i think it's a
real signal yeah yeah thank you yeah we
are really interested in trying to
understand the mechanisms ryan can you
get set up
go ahead go ahead and get set up um
we're going to take one question quickly
quick one well ryan's setting up
very quick great work um i don't know if
i understood what you
concluded about the noun replicative
versus um how did that does that square
with the three times more mutation rate
in males versus the females and also the
age dependence of
the father
and um versus no age dependence across
the primates yeah i mean i think that is
the puzzle like we always expect that
that increases with the age of the
parents right with the age of the father
the continuous divisions that happen in
the spermatogonial cells
except in pedigree data you find it's
flat
and if the
mutations are predominantly occurring
due to non-replicative sources at
similar rates in males and females then
that would be the expectation
and so that's why we think that
non-replicative mutations also have a
really big impact and this is seen in
cancer literature too a lot of you know
exogenous sources or
endogenous mutation modifiers double
strand breaks are also leading to a
large fraction of mutations
thank you priya
our next speaker is ryan shikhi from
institut patoo pasture